[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenbaum Jason nelkin is here
Jason Elkins here hey everybody you let
your hair down when the cameras are
rolling I do just for the folks at home
yeah Ryan couldn't be here but Jason's
here and uh yeah I noticed that you were
looking in the camera you're like you
know what man I'm gonna let it down
Dave's confused brother well it's tough
to work with when I'm setting things up
but when it's uh when the cameras are on
and I'm all set it's time to let the
hair down and really get comfortable
here for another episode of inside of
you what's that song lets your hair down
I don't know it's probably a lot of
stuff I'm going out tonight I'm gonna
gonna let it all hang out never mind
shut up sounds fun it sounds like a fun
thanks for listening thanks for being
here Jason Ryan couldn't be here today
but it's always a treat to have you here
when you are here always a pleasure to
be here when I am here yes that's uh
very profound and oh wow true yeah uh
what is going on we got a great freaking
guest today I'm very excited if you're
here for Carrie Anne Moss you're in for
a treat don't fast forward we got some
information if you if you dig the
podcast if you like it you go wow that
was a really good interview all I ask is
maybe you give it another shot you uh
write a review uh subscribe spread the
word a little podcast here and we could
use your help if you really dig it
inside of you podcast on Instagram and
Facebook at inside epod on the Twitter
and I think it's a great interview
um some just some quick things the
inside of you online store has amazing
stuff if you're a Smallville fan it's
got so many cool things leximus scripts
and uh ship Keys autographed and little
busts and statues and uh tumblers with
new tumblers and shirts and uh all sorts
of stuff go to the inside of you online
store get some cool merch today
um what else you can also um listen to
the podcast on anywhere except Stitcher
stitcher's going out of business so if
you're listening on Stitcher make sure
you subscribe to Apple or something else
or watch on YouTube because Stitcher is
going down
I don't know I don't know what to say
that's it uh I will be in doing some
cons in September I think we're going to
DC uh Salt Lake City nice uh yeah a lot
of stuff going on there so um and the
patrons my patrons patreon.com inside of
you if you want to join patreon and
support the podcast in extra ways
um that's pretty groovy and I'm gonna
try and do a meet up with the patrons so
if you show up to DC I think we're going
to try and get together for an hour or
so just to you know meet all the lovable
patrons who without them I couldn't do
this podcast I've said it before you
listen to it while you're editing oh
yeah yeah it's important it's like you
know I didn't I didn't know what Patron
was in the beginning and then when I
when now that I've been doing it I'm
like holy [__] this is uh
this is it baby I couldn't do it without
these guys patreon.com inside of you
I'll send you a message after you um
become a patron uh there's tons of uh
perks
um I send packages to the top tiers I
give a shout shout outs at the end of
every episode
um all sorts of cool stuff YouTube live
is where I play music and I have answer
questions and we're adding stuff to the
patron so uh it's a good place to get to
know people a lot of a lot of patrons
are friends
um all that stuff uh the band my band
sunspin.com go to sunspin.com gets the
new vinyl is out our new album never is
what it is the new Final is out get one
there's only a hundred made I think
we've already sold half of them in a few
days they're badass we're really excited
we're working on the next album
you could listen to the music anywhere
Spotify Apple
the band is Sun spin and we're doing a
stage it on the 29th I believe of July
congrats man thanks man so a lot of cool
stuff going on and I'm more importantly
I'm having fun I'm trying to have fun
and trying to enjoy the experience and
the and the process which was important
yeah um that's about it this uh next
guest uh I was surprised they got her
Kristen Ritter hooked me up with this
she uh name dropped I just name dropped
but she's a good friend and she hooked
me up with Carrie Ann Moss who I was
surprised did it you know and um we had
a great conversations she's so together
I was really surprised not surprised I
guess
I'm not surprised that most people are
more together than I am but
um it's uh it's it was refreshing and I
think she she uh
but as it goes to the Beat Around drum
marches to the beat of her own you have
to say marches to the beat can you sing
well you could say it goes to it goes to
the beat of her own Trump marches is you
know like doing in Step she marches to
the beat of Her Own Drum yeah there's a
band called The Drums by the way there's
a song called money I want to buy you
something but I don't have any money
you ever heard it the drums no the drums
money by the drums I can't say it you
gotta listen to it I think you'll dig it
I like you like metal though don't you I
like everything but I especially like
metal you do do you like Def Leppard
yeah of course sweet uh great podcast
today I hope you enjoy it uh without
further Ado let's get inside of Carrie
Ann Moss it's my point of view you're
listening to inside of you with Michael
Rose
[Music]
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
hey folks wanted to highlight something
important before today's episode in case
you weren't aware of myself and many of
the guests are on strike alongside sag
after nwga today's episode and any we
air before the strike ends were recorded
before it began so this is just a heads
up in relation to some for the topics we
may discuss if you want more info on the
strike visit
sagafterstrike.org now let's get into it
I mean I love is it true that you were
named after the Carrie Anne song by The
Holly is that true actually because
sometimes Wikipedia you know yeah it is
true I love that song yeah I was number
one the day I was born I think my mom
had um
she had another name picked for me and
then she heard the song uh well I think
after she had me and
she changed her mind so there you go
really yes I could just if you guys
haven't heard that song Hey carrion
what's your game now that's a gorilla
The Hollies right
yeah it was a fun song what was her big
hit they had a big hit
I forget I I kind of visualize it on the
other side of the the record
yeah yeah oh it's it's uh all I need is
the air that I breathe the air that I
breathe there you go oh man I missed
that music I missed the 70s and 80s I
know such a good time we were so lucky
yeah do you listen to anything now by
the way do you listen to any music now
or are you really stuck back and back in
the day no I listened to all my all the
new stuff I have a my daughter is almost
14 and we do a lot of driving together
and so
she has some pretty epic playlists and
it has introduced me to kind of all that
new you know 13 14 year old music
um which is very catchy and fun and
something I would never have any clue
about if it wasn't for her
and those long drives but
yeah I love music I love singing she
sings we sing in the car I think it's
you know I always say like
when my kids are singing uh I know
they're all well like they're you know
they're you know you can it just is like
medicine for your heart just to sing so
I love to do that and I love to do it in
my car it's happy do you sing loudly I
mean do you act like I mean if people
are watching you would you be
embarrassed if someone was filming you
never no uh maybe probably but do you
sing well you can sing well huh well I
mean I love singing I don't know if I
sing well anymore I used to think pretty
well when I was younger I went to a high
school
um in Vancouver where we had like a
really really good choir and band and so
we traveled all over Europe like singing
in all the cathedrals so I was in like a
jazz choir and in um in all kinds of
different choirs and um yeah love music
was sort of my first love I mean I
always wanted to be an actor but
I love um I love singing
um but I don't you know I only do it for
fun it's it's personal you know you know
I always said that too and I I'd rather
be a rock star than an actor or you know
it just there was something about it
that I just I just loved but I always
felt like ah you're not that great of a
singer uh you're not that great of a
guitarist you don't sing like Adam
Lambert don't do it and then all of a
sudden I turn like 45 and I was like I
just I've always loved this why not do
it and and the reason why I didn't do it
I think is because I was always worried
about what other people thought and how
they would perceive me and how they'd
put my music down and how they judge me
and then I said why is that holding you
back
and I'd said hell with it and I put
together a band and I recorded three
albums in the last three years and I'm
just like and I'm loving it and it's not
like it's making a lot of money but um
it's something I love do you have any
passions like that where you know you
you do it and you love it but you wish
that this was what you did besides
singing of course yeah
you have a real passion for
for wellness
you know if people I'm kind of I have a
detective mind
so I have a tendency to like when I'm
working on a show or something
if people are dealing with some kind of
like health issue like I
get really into it and you know I have
quite a few friends that are amazing
doctors and healers and all kinds of
things so I
I enjoy that like I think if I I never
went to college it never crossed my mind
to go to college I always wanted to be
an actor but if I was to look at kind of
what I love now I might have been a
doctor I I do enjoy like
you know I've met some really great
doctors in my time
um in my life
and doctors that really think outside
the box and are detective like and
understand you know
um more than just sort of like
individual like oh you're going to this
person for this thing and this thing
instead of like looking at the whole
person looking at your whole life
looking at your emotional life all that
I find that very fulfilling and I enjoy
doing that and I I like to come you know
to um
support people and and not that I know
and not that I know what to do but I I
listen and I research and I might offer
a perspective that they hadn't thought
of that's happened quite a few times oh
man you opened the doors Pandora's box
or Pandora
um wow well first of all you're on the
right podcast because
you know I think inadvertently this
podcast kind of evolved into mental
health and you know when I talk about my
anxiety and dysfunction and people talk
about death and Frank Grillo he's a
great actor he was just on he talked
about he lost his mother and father
within a year and
um and one of his best friends and you
know how we got through that and
you know this is something that it's
become and it's helped so many people
which I was like what I don't understand
but when guests like you talk about that
stuff
because there's there was always a
stigma you know with you know therapy
and talking about your emotions and I
think that's getting better nowadays and
it's sort of but it's it's it's very
helpful and I love that you talk about
that and it's funny you say you like
helping people on set because I text
Kristen Ritter
and I said well what can you tell me
about curious
and this is her text to me
no you ready to be embarrassed yes maybe
one of the most important people I've
ever met in my life
all the good things I know about are are
from her she's the person I go to for
mothering advice Health essential oils
when I'm not doing great she's a first
stop she's a true friend like family one
of the greatest Gifts of my life has
been her friendship and then she said
there was a day on Jessica Jones on a
season
where she got a terrible migraine she
was in really rough shape and she had to
work anyway and she can't and you can't
you had to work but you came in on your
day off
to help her through it and support her
and massage her and use your magic oils
hmm I was like what
I would never come in on my day off
I mean who does that that is just like
is that she says that's just who you are
and I had a feeling when I met you that
I'd be like oh my God
I need someone like this I need someone
so because I could just tell right away
how calming you are how I don't know
about that I mean I definitely had that
Vibe and I can't have that by but you
know I'm just like every person I have
many sides and um but I um I do love
helping people and
um I have a deep love for Kristen and I
also understand
the pressure and stress of being number
one on a show and what that takes and I
you know being older now I'm you know
three or four on the call sheet
generally and it's it's actually a super
great gift of you know a long career of
working hard and putting in all those
hours you know kind of it's it's
definitely not as vigorous in terms of
you know sometimes it is but in general
I'm making kind of a general
um assessment there but
um so yeah it was my honor to go and
support her I have three children so
Jessica Jones was like a really huge
um
sort of step out of my comfort zone
because I hadn't really left them to
work
um I'd worked a very I worked really not
very often
had to be kind of really perfect in in
terms of schedule and if I could bring
them when they were little like I never
left them and but it got harder as they
went to school so it was hard to work
it's hard to go away to work
this show is sponsored by betterhelp
sometimes in life we're faced with tough
choices and the path forward isn't
always clear whether you're dealing with
decisions around your career your
relationships or anything else therapy
helps you stay connected to what you
really want while you navigate life so
you can move forward with confidence and
excitement
trusting yourself to make decisions that
align with your values is like anything
the more you practice it the easier it
gets if you're thinking of starting
therapy give better help a try
it's entirely online so it's convenient
flexible and suited to your schedule
just fill out a brief questionnaire to
get matched with a licensed therapist
and switch therapists anytime for no
additional charge let therapy be your
map with better help visit
betterhelp.com inside today to get 10
off your first month that's better help
betterhelp.com slash inside this message
is sponsored by discover did you know
you could reduce the number of unwanted
calls and emails with online privacy
protection the latest Innovation from
discover discover will help regularly
remove your personal info like your name
and address from 10 popular people
search websites that could sell your
data and they'll do it for free
activate in the Discover app see terms
and learn more at discover.com online
privacy protection and Jessica Jones
came at a time and I said okay I'm can I
do this like can I go have an apartment
in New York and like fly back and forth
I'd fly back and forth to
la like
I don't know 20 times a month I mean I
just go to work where I'd show up work
get on the plane go back how exhausting
was that
it was it was really it was
I mean listen it was a real adjustment
um I had been living like a life of like
being really in a nourishing kind of
bubble with my children like I'm very
I love being a mom and um
so like you know
there's a rhythm to that right
and so I was really like hesitant to
step out of it but I also believe and I
also know that stretching out of your
comfort zone and doing things that feel
really like you can't do it is so good
for you and I grew so much and a lot of
that growth Kristen really supported
because like I know it sounds so silly
but like I didn't even know like really
how to use my phone like at that time
like I I really didn't Uber what like
like I mean I really had zero idea like
I was away like having kids and the
whole industry changed
um the whole world changed basically
while I was at home making breakfast
lunch and dinner you know and I was it
was like jarring and she just would like
go okay here give me your phone you know
or it sounds such a such a little tiny
thing that she did for me but
she just kind of has this really like
she's very business-minded and she's
very very creative very professional she
knows how to get things done and I I am
as well but I'd been in this sort of
softer kind of nourishing nurturing kind
of vibe that I I wasn't sure how I could
do it and so she was very supportive of
that and helped me a lot so it was
definitely our relationship is is very
equal in what we give each other
um and we care about each other we've
been through things together you know
it's tough to go to work and have a like
a headache like she had like like brutal
how did you know did you it was your day
off right so I I can't remember if she
texted me or if somebody texted me and
told me I can't remember but and you
just came to sat you said I'm just going
to set I'm going to help her yeah yeah
yeah that's extraordinary it's it's what
we all need to think about with with our
lives it feels good right it feels it's
not like it feels good to be supporting
other people it feels good to be
supported it feels good to be part of
the community it feels good to be
connected to other people and
to care you know about other people I
mean it it's only a win-win right yeah
but I don't know like are you in look I
know you're Canadian so you're probably
in you know it's it's just part of you
because I know a lot of Canadians and
they're all so such kind people like I'm
sure there are bad Canadians but for the
most part the ones that I've met there's
something calming there's something
sweet there's something honest about
them I don't know what it is
but
um is it something that you grew up with
I know your mom raised you right
was was she like that was like yeah I
mean she's she's a kind person you know
my family my fine my family are filled
with kind people for sure
um
you know I I don't know and I have to
say like Kristen
inspired something in me in that moment
like I knew that
she needed that help and
you know
you just do that when it matters right
yeah how is it like what was it like
growing up in like burning because
that's where I filmed Smallville in
Burnaby for okay for seven years I mean
I guess ten in a way
um but you know Burnaby is not the I
don't I'm not putting Burnaby down but I
just I just know it as like kind of
commercial maybe I didn't see the all
the beauty
I don't think I saw any beauty and I
think you know I live very rural now and
um I love nature and I you know I would
consider although there was a lot of
beauty I'm sure like I would notice now
but at the time you're a teenager you're
just
you know you're young you're just kind
of going to school and figuring out how
you're going to get out of there you
know like I just remember thinking
I I would look at my sidewalk and think
I cannot wait to get out of here and it
wasn't like I hated it or anything like
that and I I said that to my kids all
the time like that's part of what
motivates you to do things in your life
and you know like to have dreams and you
know to push yourself out of your
comfort zone again right to just sort of
Imagine like there's a whole world out
there
and um so growing up in Burnaby I think
if I look back at it now I had you know
I walked to school every day
um and I have kids and they've never
walked to school so we you know it's
like school is just not it's just not
like that anymore like I mean I'm sure
it is but like our schools aren't close
enough to walk although you know I
walked 45 minutes like I'm not seeing my
kids going like I'm gonna walk 45
minutes or even me saying you're gonna
walk 45 minutes it's a different time
you know we were latchkey I was a
latchkey kid
um that generation of just a different
kind of Independence I think that we
that people in my generation
um got and um I really couldn't get out
of there quick enough and as beautiful
as Vancouver is like I've never really
wanted to go back and do that
um live there or anything like that I've
considered it maybe when I first had
children you get really nostalgic about
your own life and then you go back and
you see wow it's completely changed it's
no longer the way it was and
and and you can't replicate your
childhood you just kind of bring what
you like leave the rest and
and um so yeah growing up in Burnaby I
mean I did have a lot of opportunities
that um I think is kind of interesting
I'm sure my mom was the one to figure
all that out but I was part of a group
that sang and danced all over
and like a couple of us went on to do
pretty well
um who when you say a couple of us who
were those people
um I'm forgetting right now like I know
I'm completely blanking but I think
there's two other women that ended up
having really nice careers but I'm I'm
totally
um
so that was kind of interesting you know
to because I'm always looking for those
kinds of things for for like say my
daughter and I find it kind of hard to
find
um
but I and again I went to this High
School
um public high school that you know I
was you know did plays that were like
written for our school
um I traveled all over Europe singing
you know in cathedrals with that
beautiful Acoustics and just I mean you
know going to Europe
and never have been and I remember they
they gave us like a an allowance like
for we our breakfast was always included
in like the pension or the hostel we
stayed and then you got like your lunch
money and then we would all come to
dinner so you know you had your money
for lunch and I took my money
and I got my hair cut like really short
like really like cool and short and like
a new like I look like a completely
different person but I had no money to
eat lunch
and I thought that wouldn't be a big
deal until I was like really hungry so
then I had to call my mom and she ended
up like you know wiring me right wiring
how old are you at this point I'm like
16. she's one I'm with the school right
16 yeah I'm 16. and um and my mom said
that when I got off the plane she was
just like her breath was she did her
just her breath was taken away because I
had just transformed you know I just
gone out of where I came from and and
the smell and the feel and the sound and
it just it it informed me I just always
wanted to like see what is out there
that's Brave though see I didn't have
the wherewithal or the
I I the confidence I I just I I grew up
in a small town in Indiana and I was
kind of surrounded by dysfunction you
know my family was completely you know
all over the place and I was just kind
of I just felt like this lost little kid
and of course I dreamed of like oh this
but I I just I never thought it would
would ever happen I don't know how I
mean and the way it happened was was
pretty crazy I won't bore you with that
[__] but
um oh I want to hear no no I'll tell you
some other time but it's just like you
know I I couldn't imagine I remember my
dad I went to hockey camp for a week
and that was just terrifying it was in
Canada and they left me and I
and it was just so jarring but it sounds
like
um probably 14 15. yeah and I know I
don't know it's interesting right how
did you have that because did you ever
were you anxious as a kid you have
anxiety were you sad kid were you happy
oh no no I was really you know I was
born with a very sunny disposition
um that's you know every picture of me
as a baby as I'm laughing and I remember
just
um you know I'm not saying that I don't
have that I haven't accessed some other
parts of the emotional
life of a human being but my early years
um I just
was somehow
uh I I think it it came from my mom my
mom was a young mom and like our home
was very simple we didn't have money it
was just but it never felt like
it it just felt cozy and close you know
and
I just
didn't struggle with I was always
confident and I mean listen no I'm not
saying content like you know
definitely all that girl stuff that
happens
um like in Middle School I definitely
dealt with a lot of that stuff but like
I was bullied at one point when I was in
high school
well they bully you about
um I was bullied by about three girls
who really had an issue with the fact
that I thought I was gonna do well in
life and
I don't even know how they I mean I I
wore dresses and I wanted to be a model
and
and you know their whole thing was like
I thought I was hot [__] that's what
they would write in the bathroom on the
wall or whatever and
and I mean
I mean maybe I was in like I think I was
in like 10th grade ninth or tenth grade
and they would follow me down the
hallway and just kind of like throw
things at me from the behind and like
just sort of
you know
just kind of agitate me you know
and I never went like home and told my
mom or anything like that I wasn't even
I was just
I was it was it was I think about it now
and I you know now that I have kids and
I'm just like wow I'm kind of impressed
of how how I dealt with it one day I was
um you know go in the bathroom they'd
write things in like marker about me and
stuff and
and I didn't even know them like like
you know like at lunch break me and my
best friend would sit in the sewing room
like pulling out pictures of like
supermodels in the big magazines that
you do the sewing things and we'd make
scrapbooks and we'd make vision boards
and like I was like really you know I
wasn't like super popular or anything
you know
I just I was I was not not popular but I
was just kind of like I was friends with
like everybody kind of thing you know
yeah but you didn't let these girls
bother you it sounds like you just kind
of well no what happened was is that I
was walking down the hallway in like a
skirt and like clogs you know and like
kind of they it was probably pink or
blue or something something they really
didn't like
and they were really taunting me and I
remember thinking inside of myself
I would rather they beat the crap out of
me right now than Live Another Day with
this feeling and so I turned around and
I said let's go right now
wait you challenged these three girls to
a fight yep and what happened
they walked away
what isn't that crazy they walked away
yeah that would never happen to me if I
turn around and said let's go I'd be
knocked out probably yeah I mean I don't
know maybe they were just more just
getting off on just the power and not
really wanting to execute it yeah and I
remember like I was shaking I mean I was
terrified but I was just like uh let's
go right now let's fight
and I'm in like a skirt you know and
they're in jeans and you know what I
mean like but I just was like you know
what I can't live with the this feeling
like are they around the corner are they
behind me am I gonna be walking to the
bathroom like it was this sort of
overwhelming feeling that I didn't I
decided in a moment I didn't want it
anymore and so if it meant that that we
had to face it
and work it out
and I was not like a fighter girl I mean
right right except with boys when you're
young and you're playing and you're like
the girls against the boys whatever you
know but yeah it was pretty brave
inside he was brought to you by Factor
meals let me tell you something Jason
um
this is true
a box was sent to me on my birthday
by Factor right I was like what is this
I didn't uh I didn't become a member of
factor I don't know why they sending
this to me right
and I was like oh it must have been a
gift
and uh then I found out that they're a
sponsor but I found out they're a
sponsor after I had one of their meals
whoa I had this chicken with it was like
a a mashed cauliflower almost like
mashed potatoes
with some broccoli and it was so
delicious
if it was so much healthier than any of
the stuff I eat and I was like why am I
not doing this all the time it's a quick
easy meal I'm always on the go and I was
like hell yes and then I found out yeah
they sent it to you because they're a
sponsor now I'm like get out
get out perfect this is great
um look we're in the thick of Summer
guys and you might be looking for
wholesome convenient meals to support
Sunny active days Factor America's
number one ready to eat meal kit can
help you fuel up fast with flavorful and
nutritious ready meals delivered
straight to your door that's what
happened to me straight to my door
you'll save time eat well stay on track
reaching your goals
you got to get some Factor meals this is
awesome with Factor skip the extra trip
to the grocery store and The Chopping
prepping and cleaning up too while
getting the flavor and nutritional
quality you need factors fresh never
frozen meals are ready in just two
minutes so all you have to do is heat
and enjoy and then you can get back
outside and soak up the warm weather
it's just so fast to have a meal and
it's not like because I I just keep
ordering food and wasting so much money
on these on these delivery services that
have like it's it's it's it's cheaper to
get a factor meal than it is for a
delivery service
and but for one me and grocery shopping
you often over buy and then you just
stuff Rockets never eat everything this
is I I'm gonna do this I'm gonna do this
even if they don't give me free meals
I'm gonna get this I'm gonna get Factor
meal prep is amazing meal prep is
amazing look uh if you're too busy like
me running around and all you can do is
think about lunch you go home and guess
what lunch is right there and within two
minutes you have lunch you have a good
freaking lunch effortless wholesome
meals grain bowls salad Toppers that are
ready to eat when you're on the go no
microwave required looking for calorie
conscious options this summer try
delicious dietitian approved calorie
smart meals with around or less than 550
calories per serving need an extra boost
to support your Wellness goals with
Summer try Protein Plus meals with 30
grams of protein or more per serving
head to factormeals.com inside 50 and
use code inside 50 to get 50 off that's
code inside 50 at factormeals.com
side 50 to get 50 percent off and what's
great guys is they offer a delicious
flavor packed option on the menu each
week to fit a variety of Lifestyles from
keto calorie smart vegan and veggie
Protein Plus prepared by chefs approved
by dietitians each meal has all the
ingredients you need to feel satisfied
all day long while meeting your goals
and and Jason the breakfast items look
at this I love breakfast apple cinnamon
pancakes if you want bacon and cheddar
egg bites potato bacon and egg breakfast
skillet or for an easy Wellness boost
try refreshing beverage options like
cold pressed juices shakes smoothies
with Factor you can rest assured you're
making a sustainable choice we offset a
hundred percent of our delivery
emissions Source 100 renewable
electricity for our production sites and
offices and feature sustainably sourced
Seafood in our meals this July get
factor and enjoy eating well without the
hassle simply choose your meals and
enjoy fresh flavor-packed meals
delivered to your door ready in just two
minutes no prep No Mess head to
factormeals.com inside 50 and use code
inside 50 to get 50 off that's code
inside 50 at factormeels.com inside 50
to get 50 off
[Music]
um that I did this did happen once this
guy I'm gonna I'm gonna call him I
shouldn't say his real name right I
don't know I don't even know the girl's
name I'll just say it honestly I didn't
know them at all like I didn't know them
at all well I remember this guy's name
Bryce you can bleep it if you want but
his name is Davey Barnes
and he just would always kind of like
like you said he would just like kind of
throw an eraser at me or something and I
just said you know what the [__] man and
I was really small smallest kid in my
high school and you know didn't start
puberty late
girls weren't into it I just nothing I
was I didn't exist as my brother said
because you didn't but that was with my
family he said I didn't exist but I
didn't exist really in high school and I
remember
after health education class I had my
books and this guy comes over and just
boom knocks my books out of my hand
and I just I picked them up and kind of
like I said dick
and then the next week
I walked at a class and he did it again
and I the whole class I thought I gotta
say so I'm gonna do something I'm gonna
and I just immediately went up to my
goal if you do that again I'm gonna
[__] kick your ass don't [__] do
that again I just screamed in his face
he goes whoa whoa like calm down but he
never did it again
he never did it again he could have
kicked my ass but he just
he just was like yeah I guess it's no
longer any fun when when the person that
you feel power over goes I'm not doing
this anymore yeah I'm not playing this
role anymore with you
I'm changing the dynamic I mean I'm not
saying that that's what happened I don't
know I really didn't think much of it
until I you know until I had kids and
you know and just realized wow like that
was pretty brave you know yeah yeah but
um yeah
interesting interesting to the dynamic I
think it's a lot different now
um but I'm sure people get bullied still
and I mean online and all that crazy
crazy stuff yeah was your was your dad I
mean I don't know if you want to talk
about was your dad around or was he yeah
I was um um I was raised by my
stepfather until I was about 14
um and my parents got divorced but I
actually didn't meet my real father
until I mean I knew when I was a baby
and then um was re-acquainted with him
around 14 and then um
um yeah and I'm close to my my
biological fathers now like you know we
have a relationship my stepfather passed
away when I was um 27 I think right is
is it kind of my relate I have to say
that when I think of my childhood I
think of my mom and my brother and I you
know that was my like when you you know
you think about your your core people
like that's the image that I have in my
mind did you have like I'm sure you
weren't like immediately like all right
we're
you know when you're 14 he hasn't been
really in the picture and you're saying
why weren't you around did you have all
those questions well yeah I mean I think
I processed a lot of um
yeah you process throughout your life
whatever it is I think a lot of
I mean
you know I don't think I was aware of it
I think when I became you know started
acting
um I think acting is really part of why
a lot of us are drawn to it you really
do get to work out a lot of your own
stuff through the work which is kind of
incredible obviously can be hard if
you're not if you don't have a good
groundedness in yourself but
yeah I mean I think
I think I don't I don't have those
feelings anymore
um you know those feelings of
Abandonment or
or whatever I don't even really remember
and that's what I love about life right
is that
if you look at any opportune any
situation in your life
um that's challenged you or that you
have an emotional
um agitation to word
you have the opportunity to completely
transform it and heal from it and that's
how I've grown in my life is I've looked
at anything negative
um and felt the feelings gone through
whatever I need to go through and then I
always ask myself what can I learn
and that's to me like
a super like a super skill yeah that
really is I mean um it's like real
interesting too it took me too long to
sort of just accept forgive and just
move on and I think whether you like it
or not for me I think that there's still
that inner child buried deeply in there
that still feels certain things and then
as long as you could pinpoint and sort
of that's why I'm acting like that or
that's why I feel that way that's not a
real feeling that's because you felt
that as a kid that's not now and when I
was able to forgive you know my parents
and sort of
through a lot of therapy and
EMDR
and all other things but when I was able
to do that it was cathartic it was
certainly something that helped me and I
I believe that when you forgive
and you could truly get past something
that's the healing that's the that's
when you start to feel better and you
know all all the things that take over
or feel like so overwhelming like
anxiety and depression all these things
they start to go away because a lot of
them are caused by those feelings you
know that you don't let go and you hold
on and they're just so yeah I I
understand that I think that's that's a
beautiful way of looking at it like just
I seeing the bright side of things and
things get dark and people have a lot
a lot of dark [__] but
um
yeah I think forgiveness is huge uh we
haven't even talked about your career
good God I but I like this I told you
um this is what I like to talk about
um
so you started acting at a young age was
your mom very cool about it like yeah
this is what she wants to do she wants
to go be a model when did you know you
wanted to become an actor
uh my whole life for sure like since I
was really little what was it
huh what was it about acting oh well I
think I mean at the time I thought it
was just this Divine calling but now I
think it was just because I watched so
much TV
you know yeah I grew up watching a lot
of TV and I think that it just sort of
like
um permeated my my being and I wanted to
be a Storyteller you know I wanted to be
a part of telling stories
and you know I my mom was not supportive
of me doing anything like as a young
person like I was part of these these
you know dance troops and singing groups
but she said when you're old enough to
do it on your own then you know take
yourself to an audition but which is
such good advice and I I highly
recommend that to people with kids
um it's better to wait
um
and and then I just um yeah I started
modeling I guess when I graduated high
school
I wasn't sure like how to be an actor I
didn't know what you do I never knew
well I did know someone who was an actor
because at my school Michael J fox went
to my school and she's crazy did you
know it yeah you went to my elementary
school well he was older than me but I
knew of him
and of course there are so many Canadian
Actors now but at the time
um you also didn't know if people were
Canadian right because we didn't have
Wikipedia or you didn't you know you
didn't know someone's bio or whatever
so I it just seemed kind of like an un
like I don't know how do you do that
um
but my dream was pretty
um the the fire in me was pretty strong
did you say that yeah go continue yeah I
always have questions that I'm thinking
of the go yeah yeah and then I moved to
um I moved to Toronto to model and I was
modeling there and then I moved to then
went to Japan and did there and then I
moved to Europe
um
and I was in Spain and modeling and
stuff like that and then I had an
audition when I was in Spain for a TV
show like an American TV show like a CBS
crime time after prime time kind of and
I got like this little part
that was a regular role like in Spain
like what's the likelihood that would
happen and I was terrible in it and
um and then they the next season was in
LA and so I drove to LA and you know had
no money no car no green card no
I got my side card from that show and I
got a work visa from that show but I
mean I I mean
I don't even know how I did it I mean
how did we even book airline tickets
back then I have no idea but without a
credit card or whatever like was I going
there with cash and like handing the
cash I mean I have no clue
um but I do know we were calling collect
when we called home
and then I came to LA and and um and I
was in LA that was someone I turned I
was just turning 25 and um
and I just started working
a little bit just enough and
then I
got the Matrix you know and I mean you
did a lot of other stuff before that
yeah yeah I mean I did TV I did you know
I think I was just talking to a friend
about this I did models Inc when I was
20. a six or something
um which was an Aaron Spelling show yeah
and at the time you know like all those
air inspiring shows were so big and I
think that probably that show was the
biggest learning curve and what set the
tone for my whole career because the
show was supposed to be huge
um we did publicity before we we got
into the the publicity
um wheel before the show even shot a day
of the show
and I always
thought that was odd
and I never got caught in it like
believing it
that's good
and it you know it wasn't a successful
show we did one season
and
I understood
pretty early on that
our business is very unpredictable
and I use this analogy a lot
um I always looked at our business like
a big fat alcoholic
that
um Charming
great fun
but don't rely on it
and so I always had that attitude and
not in a negative way
but in a very kind of like you know I
never really thought about how a show
was going to do or a movie was going to
do or I you know if it did really well
like I enjoyed it but I didn't buy into
any of it so I know how quickly I just
like it's this right it's it's boy are
you lucky are you you're lucky that you
had sort of that
subconscious I don't know Insight or
whatever yeah really grateful it really
served me really really well yeah I
didn't have that I was like this is
going to be huge I know it's going to be
great and so you get bombs like oh my
god what happened why why this bomb is
it because of me uh the reviews are bad
I thought this was I thought this was
gonna make it yeah there's all those
things so I'm it's amazing at that age
that you could say okay you kind of
learned from that show that yeah I
learned that that was like so that was
school for me I mean I think of life as
school right we're cons we're in school
learning about
so many different
facets of life
and that was really amazing like I
remember when the Matrix came out and it
was really huge and I was with some
friends we were in like on a vacation
somewhere and I really don't ever really
do that so it was kind of a big deal
and they a few of the friends were like
in the business and we're calling the
phone line to find out the numbers like
I didn't even know there were the
numbers
do you know what I mean like I I
certainly didn't know that you called
some line to get the numbers and they're
telling me and I'm like
okay
um that's
that's cool I mean
I don't know I mean you weren't excited
or you were just like
no I did I just didn't really buy into
it
I think the only time that I got really
excited about it was I went to a theater
that wasn't a like Premiere Theater
where you know the Applause and stuff
like that like half the people in the
room made the movie and so it's really
hard it's not a gauge of you know you
know the truth and I went to like
Hollywood
um went in to see the movie with an
audience like a real audience
and um
and the response that uh that floored me
that just floored me and
and especially the lineup hadn't seen
that since I was a kid going to movies
and stuff and then
you know within the first few minutes of
the movie with people completely
cheering for the character that I played
I was just like that moved my heart in a
way that like that felt really amazing
but it wasn't like I was looking outside
of myself for that validation I just
felt so good and
and then to see all the conversations
and stuff that people would have and
yeah it was really cool but I
I don't know I just don't attach myself
to the for to the outcome or the or the
end result of anything because you just
don't know you don't know
and as soon as you start to
you know get your self-worth from those
kinds of external things
um
your world becomes so difficult whereas
if you stay in yourself and you know
that you're enough whether you're
working or not working whether your
movie did great
or it didn't do great and the other
attitude that I always have and maybe
this is goes back to the first story
about Kristen is
I it matters to me the impact I have on
an actual set
um as a human being with the crew with
the cast
um for me if I look at every job that
I've done I I probably wouldn't be able
to tell you much about what it it's
about or I mean obviously Matrix and
Memento probably you know some things of
course because I've had to talk about
them so much but but what I remember are
the relationships I had with different
crew members different things that
happened babies that were born
um you know family members that died
like
um those are the things that I remember
when I watched oh yeah I remember that
day that happened like
you are an anomaly do you understand
this no I'm not I'm not I'm not you are
an anomaly I I I just I am the opposite
of that and and try have tried and have
improved where I didn't get that
validation at home I didn't get that
love I didn't get that unconditional
feeling that you know you had that you
carried with you and so I looked for
external things I looked for if I got
this part uh I'm good it must mean I'm
good everybody likes me my age are happy
people are happy and then it's a success
and then oh it's uh par okay I but it's
like you know I always say it's like
yeah and I had a head moment listen I
had moments of that too
um especially in the beginning and I
just decided pretty early on that that
was a really shitty way to live yep it
is and so like and and to be honest like
I would have people that didn't really
believe that this was genuine like what
I'm talking about because maybe they
hadn't seen it but I believed that if a
job had my name on it it was mine and
that I had to show up and do the work
but if it had your name on it then that
was your your destiny like I brought
this sort of larger view
um not only because I
it felt good to do that but I knew that
I wouldn't be able to handle the
rejection and all of those things if I
was holding on or you know com I'm a
very competitive person
but I'm not competitive in that way like
if I want a job like I want to get that
job but I adding this layer of face in
my journey just it just makes everything
it makes you so much more relaxed when
you walk into the room it makes you
because I've gone into rooms really
wanting a job and thinking you know it's
gonna like I need the money and and you
know people will think I'm good and you
know all those things it doesn't feel
good
so I just was like okay so I want to do
this I'm here I'm making enough money
you know and I'm so lucky I'm in that
small percentage of people who actually
make enough money to pay my bills and I
don't have to have another job yet
um but like how am I gonna actually do
this and keep doing it
and I was like I'm gonna have to crack
this code
I'm gonna have to crack the code that if
I'm on my couch and I'm not working that
I know that I'm enough
and that was not easy to do but it
became the work
yeah
that's amazing
I would say do you um I know you
probably talked talked about this ad
nauseam but was The Matrix the most
difficult job you've ever it had to be
at that at that point but like
physically mentally the amount of work
um was it something you didn't expect in
terms of preparation you were like I
couldn't imagine the amount of work it
actually was when you first signed it
was set to Joy like every minute of it
was such a joy that I think I I did
tougher movies that were like you know
low budget in the winter in Toronto cold
and like you know no you know what I
mean like doing nights like like that's
hard right The Matrix of course it was
so much work but we had so much support
um which I had never had before so we
have you know you have your trainer and
you have somebody making your food and
you've got a driver and you know Keanu
and I became very close to that process
he was very supportive and Lawrence was
super supportive and Hugo we had this
family relationship that supported us so
um I never think of it like oh my God
that was hard like
I I would go to work even when I didn't
work just to watch because I didn't want
to miss any of it you know because I was
like I've been watching Keanu or
Lawrence or Hugo practicing that fight
for four months I gotta go see it I
gotta see what it looks like um I mean
and this was pre being married and
pre-happing children you know I can't
really do that anymore because
um you know I'll do it occasionally if
there's something that I really want to
see but in general I don't really I
don't go to work anymore but I mean for
like resurrections that just came out
which is freaking incredible I mean what
how much harder if you look back when
you were a lot you were you were younger
when the first Matrix came out how I
mean how many years it was 30. yeah and
now doing this how much harder for you
to tackle this immense project
again we have the support and
um and I was just so excited about doing
it
um there was a lot of mental preparation
that had to go into some of the action
um the actual physical action you know I
didn't do a heck of a lot
um
um so you know it was it was different
um but I was just so happy
to be a part of it because I just didn't
see that coming you know I think of
myself as pretty intuitive I have really
good like
you know senses and like that really
shocked me yeah and people were always
saying that they thought that it would
happen I was like no way like that is
never happening so I was really shocked
was there a was there did you really
have three hours to uh of an audition
process or training for an audit for the
audition for the original Matrix
oh my gosh I had way more than that
um I think I did about six auditions for
that and one of the pieces of the
audition was three hours of fighting was
action
one part of it was that was you know
getting with the wire team the you know
the Hong Kong
um Team Masters
um and they would just sort of go
through the motions and you know
videotape the person and just you know
punching kicking doing this doing that
and um I remember it always made me
laugh that
the director said that when they got my
video
um they were like
you know every time they would kind of
cut back to the guy that I was fighting
he was patting himself up more and more
so I was actually hitting the guy and
like I didn't I didn't know about like
you know you know hit I mean I mean I
don't know how to do that so I was just
you know I could I could not walk the
next day I had the an acting audition
uh for it it was pre-going to do like
the screen test with Keanu and I was
with the directors and I'm sitting in
the chair doing like one of the big
scenes of like waking him up I think at
the end of the movie and I did it one
time and the directors I think it was it
was actually my birthday my 30th
birthday and the directors asked me if I
could stand up
and I said I actually can't you know and
you think about it right you're up for a
big movie you do anything
right like I actually couldn't like I I
was in so much pain
um in places in my body that I didn't
even know like that you had muscles
there you know it was it was intense wow
did you know that was there someone else
in the in the running with you
I mean I didn't know I mean now you hear
everybody was up for it it's like kind
of funny hey my husband will go oh
so-and-so said they were up for I didn't
I wasn't privy to any of that and
and you know they let me know I was I
think they had like a week to tell me
after the screen test you know you sign
everything right just like if you're
doing a series or whatever right and um
and so they had a week to tell me and
then come that Friday they asked for
another week
because I think they really didn't want
me and I think the directors were really
fighting for me
um I really didn't think I was going to
get that like again though I trusted
like if my name's on it my name will be
on it like how great it is just to
you know have the auditions and I met
you know Keanu and we had such a lovely
connection and
I just felt like wow this is this is
true this is turning my career whether I
get this or not because I'm experiencing
something that I have never experienced
and that energy will I'll take with me
to the next thing or whatever I really
did not think in a million years that I
would ever get it yeah I I worked I was
completely shocked completely shocked
I worked with piano and I did a movie
called Sweet November and I was in Drag
and I worked with him for a couple weeks
and every Dance I mean I honestly when
people ask me about Keanu I'm like
I have these videos that I I still have
I never even watched again of like us on
set and I'd come in and drag and I go
hello can too you know and he'd be like
hello how are you good to see you and I
was like and we would talk about stuff
and he'd you know always tell me about
the the movies and he was just like
such a great guy like I'm not I'm not
even sugarcoating it it was like I had
nothing his work ethic like he just
wants to be the best that he can be and
he wants to put as much into it and
that's it I only worked with him two
weeks you've known him practically 20
something years and like I mean you've
probably said it a million times but
what's the one thing that you think of
when you think of piano
oh gosh
I mean he's such a good person
um and you know a good person seems so
silly
um he's so thoughtful you know he really
um
supported me
through that process and we were
definitely Partners in
in the evolution of that Journey
and um
yeah I couldn't I couldn't imagine it
any other way than you know he just was
so supportive and and such a good friend
we still are such good friends and
you know he's really thoughtful and he
works really hard so you you have a
vision of the bar great carrion that's
great
[Laughter]
yeah you have like you have you do these
things with someone you know
you go through things with other people
and that whatever it is right in our
lives with friends with colleagues with
family members good bad whatever you
know it
it it informs you and impacts you and
yeah he's definitely impacted me in a
very positive way was it overwhelming
working with uh Christopher Nolan on
Memento was that was that oh no not at
all that was like he was so such a
gentleman and he was so
um that was such an incredible I really
as an actor that was my favorite job
I've ever done oh yeah
um
because you know that feeling that you
have which I have felt in acting class
but is very hard to get between action
and cut
where you forget
that you're acting yeah it's really
really tough you know and it's like you
get I mean I've maybe had it I would say
in on screen like
two or three times
you know it's that it's that fleeting
right it it's that fleeting
um you know where you forget
you just didn't and um he created that
energy and
um I
really love that like like Trinity for
instance
like I love her
it was challenging to play here because
she's so still
and every movement it's like you know
what I mean it's so upright it's so
you know centered there's this quality
of
of Stillness with her that isn't really
my like I have to like I had to put a
lid on like every little thing and at
the same time access the life right and
right that's
you know at times I would feel
completely
um like just the mark on the floor just
the T that we stand on like I would feel
like that was jail you know what I mean
like I just like was like
can I not have a tea like I mean I
literally it was like that like can we
take the middle T out like I'm already
confined enough I I need the mental
bandwidth to like Channel something
right and of course the directors are so
brilliant and the shots are so brilliant
you know but with with with Memento like
and as I'm moving my body I can just
feel like how free I felt there was a
freedom in the acting
um that I really enjoy I like that like
I love like 70s 80s movies right I like
that naturalism and that a shot that
holds the actors and lets them breathe
and act and it's not so many cuts
right I love that I love the breath of
the moments I love not knowing what's
happening
so I really got to have that experience
with Christopher Nolan and he was not
intimidating I I I that's like a word I
would never imagine to use
for him I love that I mean that shows
you that shows you the confidence in a
director when they're like they don't it
doesn't have to be this it just I want
you to feel what you're feeling I want
we really stepped back he created the
environment and then guy and I just were
like dancing like it was really it was
really fascinating
you know you did all that work on that
really great script and and um and then
really allowed us the space to um have
the freedom I love it that's how I felt
anyway yeah I love Guy Pierce
yeah me too I think he's the best part
of uh LA Confidential I think he's like
the best in everything he does I I just
am engaged and uh I'm straight but I
think he's hot
he's a great guy
he's an amazing actor he's a very good I
remember at the time and not that it
matters right like Awards who cares but
like I was really surprised that he he
didn't yeah receive that for those kinds
of accolades because he was so good
yeah he always who knows how all that
all that you've won a lot of awards by
the way
huh you've won a lot of awards
but
you know
and I won one for that like my a spirit
award which I was completely shocked
about like but
I think about it now I'm like why wasn't
he there like
that's weird yeah anyway we know how all
that stuff goes now and and yeah do you
have Awards do you have Awards like at
your house or do you just not even yeah
I got a few and I kind of don't know
what to do with them
um I was actually the only reason I'm
actually thinking about it right now is
because I have an office up here and I
was like it's kind of like it's it's a
loft space it's really got a great Vibe
it has no door and it's kind of it's
kind of tricky like you hit your head
like on the on the wall on the ceiling a
lot and I have a lot of books like I
love books and I have a few of these um
these Awards and I was like what do you
do with them like where do you put them
I got my Saturn award up there my
friends makes fun of me they're like
yeah where's your Uranus award I'm like
shut up all right bad joke all right
this is called [__] talking with Carrie
Anne Moss these are my top tier patrons
they just ask quick questions it's rapid
fire Nico P what was your experience
like on the TV show Chuck uh I just
talked to Zach and I go what do you have
to say text me goes she's insanely
talented and gorgeous and I completely
geeked out on that show when she's right
maybe I had a lot of fun again that was
a job that I like a job I was shot in LA
and it was the first time I'd gone to
work since I I'd had kids like like it
was sort of like a tryout like could I
do it I went to work and I was like in
shock like everyone's on their phones
right on the set like like I just
literally felt like I had stepped into
like the weirdest like the whole world
changed um but that was fun I enjoyed
that he's really talented yeah yeah
Yvonne so good
um yeah that's great Leanne who was the
one person that believed in you when no
one else did and have you ever paid it
Forward
um oh well my mom has always believed in
me
um and I have to say that anyone who
didn't
gave me a gift because it fueled me
yeah and have I paid it Forward I hope
so yeah I think you're paying it forward
right now talking to me telling me about
all these things I just want like I'm
like oh maybe the first thing I could do
selfishly is go I think Gary and Moss
can help me I uh okay so you're are you
you're still you're the founder of
Annapurna living right
and which is so cool it's a Lifestyle
brand designed to empower women through
mindfulness meditation and devotion
um
how often how much do you work on that
and what do you do and is there anything
that we can do out there is there like
the organization to donate or or is it
just kind of just informing them how to
live a better life uh it's it's it's a
labor of love for me I actually
um haven't have offerings that I do like
I've done different courses
um I'm doing sort of a a monthly yearly
thing right now which is all about
Crossing thresholds
um and
um we're yeah I I let what I do there is
something that I do
um sometimes in the car while I'm
waiting for my daughter
um I make videos I've made a lot of
content because when I was
you know having my kids it started out
kind of mother-centered now it's not so
much it's just really more woman
centered and about like connecting to
yourself and not looking outside of
yourself for the answers and not
thinking like somebody else is going to
like tell you how to live your life that
you have all the answers like just
bringing women back home to like knowing
that they're enough and that that no one
else knows them better than themselves
and that yeah you may need support and
help here and there but ultimately if
that support and help is not helping you
to go back home into your own self then
it's not really helping you know what I
mean so so we um have conversations on
different themes
um I've done this for seven years I used
to I hold a monthly call
um kind of like a circle now I do it
only four times a year but I did it
every month on the full moon for almost
seven years even when I was promoting
The Matrix like I had all these women
and we would just talk about like the
messiness of life and like listen I
don't have it figured out I'm not an
expert but I'm sure like into like
exploring and we use poetry we use
writing prompts
um just to connect
because the Life Is Life Is So
distracting and there's so much
um pull from the self and into like all
these different you know labels and like
you did that and arguments and like
sides it's like
we need people who like are connected to
themselves and when you're connected to
yourself you know what you need and you
know how to show up and so that's what I
do and
um yeah it's been a real labor of love
for me um it's made me grow a lot and
making all the videos and stuff
um and holding space I love to hold
space for other people's growth
not because
I know the answer but I know how to hold
space
and I love doing that so
it's um something that I'm not afraid of
I'm not afraid of that so I've just um I
decided when I started on Pro living
that I was sort of tired of like being
hired for a job that I want to produce
my own stuff I want to make my own
videos like my videos in the beginning
like were with my iPhone on the kitchen
floor because it was the only quiet
place with terrible lighting and like
and and I go oh that's really you know
that looks kind of crappy and I was like
that's the myth I want to bust like
that's what I want to like you know like
I do a video because I taught meditation
a lot in the beginning I don't really do
that anymore
um but I'd be like
oh I should really redo that get into a
better light and I'd be like I don't
want to lie and then you know women
would comment oh Carrie Anne looks
really tired and I just wouldn't even
engage in that conversation
that's so freaking so you're awesome
like I just I refuse to engage in the
conversation and just get people used to
seeing like real people like I'm a
householder I'm a mom I'm I'm making
this video you know in in my living room
or wherever I don't have I'm I'm pushing
the button myself I'm editing it my I'm
not I didn't edit it because I don't
know how to do that but
you know my one person that works with
me you know
I didn't I didn't want it Sleek I didn't
want it to look great like
I just wanted it to be like
real but that's what it always is that's
what you know you spend your time on you
don't but proverbial you on on Instagram
and you're looking at these things oh my
God that's beautiful and look at that
this is look where they are and it's all
the sun and the lighting and oh my God
everybody's got a better life and
everybody and it's like stop live your
life it's all alive and by the way would
it even if it's not a lie it's not yours
it's not your life live your own make
your own life beautiful that's what I
keep trying to tell myself yeah I mean
when I I remember when I was in Khan and
Matrix was at Khan and I was pregnant
with my first son and I met that really
fancy La cap hotel or whatever you know
and I remember being there and going
well this is really pretty
but this is not what makes a life
and I looked around you know I mean
throughout my years in Hollywood and I
know really great people I've never I've
had such a blessed experience in
Hollywood with people that I've met in
my experiences and everything but I was
like
you know being successful having money
is never going to you know heal those
places inside and of course it's so
cliche we know that
but I was like
I can't wait to go home I think I left
that pressed junket early because I was
really pregnant I just needed to be home
you know and
I just and it wasn't like I was there
going oh my God I'm freaked out it's
this or that I just could see through it
you know what I mean and
I I'm not impressed by all of that it's
lovely I love a good hotel I love a good
bed in a hotel I love you know coffee
being brought to me like you know I I do
love all of that but
if you know your actual life like
if you know if you can't find the joy in
the mundane you're totally [__]
you're totally [__] because most of
your life will be mundane so I decided I
was gonna love that and I do like I love
the mundane that doesn't mean there
aren't times when I'm like I have to
unload the dishwasher a [__] another
time like right but but then I go okay
this is my life loading the dishwasher
unloading the dishwasher making the
dishes cleaning doing driving working
flying organizing all of these things
are facets of my life
and I consciously decide to enjoy that
and I have little tricks that I use to
encourage that way of thinking
and that's I've been committed to that
can you email me those thoughts
sure uh look I'm not gonna keep you
anymore this has been so me you are
you're the real deal and honestly in the
beginning you know you hear you know
people you interviewing you talk to and
you're like you know it doesn't affect
me it doesn't
and you're like and then but after
talking to you it's like this is who you
are and it's such a beautiful
it's just a beautiful way to be to live
and I think everyone should try and do
that I think you just you're real you're
you're as real as it gets Kristen said
it and uh it's you so much Insight you
don't even know that you gave me like
it's it's therapy for me but like for
people listening you know I could sit
here and ask you oh what's the number
one thing that you would say uh for
mental health or what would you do well
there's there's a lot of things you
could do you know one is disconnect and
meditation and
um I I just I really enjoyed this this
has been a real treat you're a treasure
and I'm so glad you you made this happen
so yeah thank you thanks for having me
my pleasure yeah well I wish you the
best and uh and maybe you're on
Instagram and all that right
uh I don't actually I have someone that
manages that I don't enjoy
um Instagram at all I have to say
um I was on there recently because um a
friend of mine is kind of going through
something and we're raising money for
him and I was kind of looking at it
without the sound and without even
reading and when I was on Instagram a
few years ago it was people take
pictures and right now it's just like
talking talking people are talking
talking talking and I'm not even
listening to the words
I'm not even reading but I can feel
the frequency of it is really really low
and affect affecting you know because I
believe in frequency and energy how
toxic that is and I'm seriously like I
have no idea what anyone was saying they
could have been saying the most
incredible things there's just this
manicness right because you're scrolling
from person to person I just I so I I do
have a presence there but I honestly I
don't I don't do it and of course it
would really help my Annapurna living if
I would do that
um but at this moment in time I just
there's it's it's like everything I'm
teaching or sharing because I don't
consider myself a teacher but everything
I'm sharing is the exact opposite so
it's kind of tricky like how do you
promote something where you have to go
into the into the portal that's actually
creating this dysfunction to start with
yeah did you say portal did you say
portal yeah
you know what I mean yeah yeah yeah no
you're right
I can't quite reconcile that with my
integrity
and yet I do have a presence there
because you know and and I'm and I'm not
saying that I won't go on it I'm not
trying to be like holier than that I
just don't enjoy it yeah
so I'm trying to find different ways you
know doing podcasts are great too I've
you know I've been on lots of different
podcasts I do enjoy talking to people
and and
um and I would rather do that kind of
thing than than you know I it's
interesting because at Enterprise living
what I'm saying is that your life is not
for sale there's nothing to buy
right so how can I sell something Market
something that is just basically
telling someone there's nothing you need
to buy to be better
wow including my course or anything I'm
doing like you have it in you so you
know I'm finding my way it's fun it is a
labor of love well keep shooting on
shitty quality keep uh you know keep it
real and yeah you definitely don't look
old so that woman you think you should
block her and when this comes out I'll
send you stuff and if you want to post
it great it's just good for I just think
it's good for people that yeah all that
stuff I'm just not really good at all
that stuff Kristen's great at it I'm a
little bit more like I don't know how to
do half of it and I'm gonna slow down
because I think it's going to help me uh
you're the best thanks for uh thank you
it was a pleasure have a great day
thanks for having me
there there she was Carrie Ann Moss
Carrie Ann I just want to say thank you
for being on the podcast I think you're
terrific you're a wonderful human being
and a wonderful actress and thank you
for uh being here I hope you guys
enjoyed it
um fun times Jason great times great
times great times fun times if you
didn't listen to the intro go back
there's tons of information about where
I'm going to be I'm also on the Cameo uh
join Patron
patreon.com
inside of you uh become a patron today
I'm about to read out the top tiers of
the patron they get their name shouted
out at the end of every episode
um that was a really wonderful episode
so uh thanks for listening I've been
having problems with my dog Charlie kind
of problem my puppy
well I think he's got separation anxiety
he's been fine he's never chewed up
anything except a nibble on a pillow or
you know little things that I'm like all
right he's a dog I uh I was downstairs
and I heard him whining and we were just
downstairs I was alphabetizing my DVD
collection who has DVDs I do still and
um
I came back up probably 30 minutes later
and he had chewed a whole piece of the
stair carpet off insane and then uh you
know I just I didn't you know obviously
I don't hit my dog but I yelled at him
and I
put his face in it and said no he saw
the mess everywhere and you know and he
felt shame and then and then
um I thought that'd be the end of it I
sprayed bitter apple on it so he
wouldn't chew it again and then I went
out for two and a half hours I came home
and he had ripped up the rest of it wow
determined to destroy yeah and so I'm
not sure what exactly to do so I'm gonna
get a trainer involved and
um yeah you can't have your puppy
destroying your house
I gave him a wonderful home to live in I
treat him like a king and he shits on me
what does he do he shits on me but you
know they're puppies what are they gonna
do what are they gonna do yeah and you
can't punish him an hour later when he
doesn't know what the hell he did no
they can't exactly think too rationally
I hate that excuse where it's like he
doesn't remember his brain is the P I'm
like no no he knows what he did he still
feels shame he's in he's in the corner
going looking at me like no they know
cool are we cool yeah they have the same
look humans yeah you know what you did
yeah I'm not gonna go for that I'm like
I look at him I'm like I know no don't
come over to me I don't want to touch
you I'm not petting you right now
unfortunately you can't have a prolonged
discussion about it with him where you
really break down how it hurts you yeah
because you really hurt my feelings
ultimately the brains are peace I work
hard to make this house look nice so you
could live in it I give you endless
amounts of toys and treats yeah I hope
you didn't hear that anyway thanks for
listening uh all my love Jason thanks
again for being here great to be here
yeah you can say whatever you want great
to be here yeah I knew a little secret
that we talked about before but I won't
say anything about you and your life oh
[__] I'm not going to mention it okay
okay your girlfriend won't listen
no well maybe she might hear me editing
this oh yeah so we'll stop now what was
that about
I'll tell her uh thank you uh that's
about it we're gonna give the shout outs
these are the top tier patrons these are
folks that give extra to the show which
make it makes it possible for me to do
it to do the show here they are I love
you all
Nancy D Leah s and Kristen K they're now
a Duo usually it was just Leah s and
Kristen K notes Leah s and Kristen k
I'm sure one day Kirsten will go I want
to be first
hi Kristin thanks for the birthday
wishes little Lisa hi little
Yukiko Jill e Brian H Nico P Robert B
Jason W Sophie M Raj C Joshua D Jennifer
and Stacy L Stacy's mom we did this last
time so his mama's got it going on Jamal
f
Janelle beam like El Dan Supremo hi Dan
hi Mike Janelle 99 more has always been
there Santiago am where's my statues
I love you buddy Chad W Leanne P Maddie
s Belinda and Dave Hall hello Dave nice
to see you Dave hi Dave Dave what's up
we love you Dave Sheila G
not to be confused with Sheila E
Brad d Ray tab of the T Tom and Talia M
Betsy D Angel Emery and see Cory K Dev
next and Michelle a Jeremy C Brandy dia4
Joanne Eugene and Leah Corey JK Jake B
not Jake Busey Angela F Mel asks
Christine s Eric H Shane R Andrew M Tim
L Amanda R Jen B Kevin e Stephanie K
Jarrell jam and Jay and Leanne Jay Luna
R Mike F Stone H Stonehenge can't forget
that Brian L Kendall L Meredith I Kara C
Jessica B Kyle F Marisol P Estevan G
Kaylee J Bryant a Ashley F Marion Louise
L Jason nelkin Romeo B Veronica Q Frank
B gen T Nikki L April R Cassie B I was
I'm not on the patreon no thank you to
those could you imagine you're giving me
like money every month maybe work with
me Twisted that'd be a weird wow stuff
weird wild stuff from the holiday
holiday world from the Hollywood Hills
in Hollywood California I am Michael
Rosenbaum I'm Jason nelkin in here for
range here for Ryan tears yes uh we'll
wait to the camera we love you guys
thank you so much for your support and
um
be good to yourself be good to yourself
do you say be good to yourselves
or to get to yourself you're talking to
the the viewer be good to yourself yeah
all right
[Music]